America's cities they are in chaos the
Democrats who have been in charge now
for decades have failed to uphold their
most basic and fundamental
responsibilities and that is the safety
the security of their fellow Americans
now here's today's cover of the New York
Post crimes ravaged City cries out for
help
de Blasio bill do something and actually
comrade de Blasio well he's done a lot
of things a lot of horrible things
that's destroying New York City it's
costing many lives the anti-crime
plain-clothed police officers and the
NYPD that unit has been disbanded he has
completely eliminated the effective
policy that we call stop and frisk
he cut the NYPD budget by over a billion
dollars and now state lawmakers might
force police to by their own personal
insurance for liability lawsuits I guess
my only advice if I'm going to be a
friend to the people I love
frankly adore and admire for the
sacrifice service and the risk they take
for all of us I guess if you're a cop
and you can retire now is the time if
you're new on the job you might want to
think about another job New York City is
basically giving you the middle finger
and they're also making it impossible to
do your job to protect and concerned and
serve your local community I mean while
far-left Governor Andrew Cuomo well he
signed off on that insane idiotic bail
reform policy he's the one that signed
the bill that allows violent offenders
to get out of jail the exact same day
without posting a penny in bail nothing
whatsoever in other words the
consequences of these soft on crime
policies it is now dire in New York City
and State shootings in New York City
they're up by a hundred and thirty
percent murder is up by 30 percent
burglaries they're up a whopping 118
percent on Monday a 14-year old was shot
three times and broad daylight on the
streets now before I show you the next
tape the old warning what you're about
to see is extremely graphic now look at
this happen this happened over the
weekend a man shot dead in the Bronx in
New York while walking you see that
little six year old little daughter
girl across the street and you see the
guy in the car right there he points the
gun and assassinates that man in broad
daylight horrible
the poor girl ran for her life and fear
and on Sunday video captured this
gut-wrenching scene two gunmen cornered
three individuals at the end of a hall
they opened fire they killed two of the
men severely wounding another Cuomo de
Blasio what do you have to say about
this you're allowing this to happen and
let me tell you what's happening in New
York is the direct result of de Blasio
and Cuomo's failed policies when laws
are not enforced when police budgets are
slashed when cops are not supported when
criminals get out of jail without any
bail chaos carnage predictably
will always ensue always it's not a hard
mathematical formula and now Democrats
across the country they now are arguing
they want to completely defund and
dismantle all law and order and all
Police Department's and the Socialists
and the so-called squad in Congress well
they just unveiled this genius bill to
strip police funding congresswoman Omar
is now calling for the entire system to
be quote dismantle the entire system
we're gonna get rid of every cop every
law enforcement official alright we go
back to the simple basic fundamental
question who will you the American
people call in an emergency after these
Democrats dismantle the police who were
you gonna call because this is what will
happen if Democrats get their way
take a look you have reached the 911
police emergency line due to defunding
of the police department we're sorry but
no one is here to take your call leave
your name and number and someone will
get back to you our estimated wait time
is currently five days goodbye the
presidents had is exactly dead-on
accurate unfortunately and the truth is
Democrats who want a deep fund police
they don't care about your safety they
don't care about your security they
don't care if your business gets looted
they don't care about arson they don't
care if your neighborhood is actually
even taken over
vandals and anarchists they live behind
gated communities they're walled off
compounds many have the ability to pay
for their own private security or they
even use your tax dollars to protect
them and so year after year decade after
decade they ignore the violence and make
no mistake if Democrats if they get
their way what is happening in New York
what's happening in Chicago what's
happening in Seattle and in California
that'll be coming to a town new year you
a neighborhood near you let's call it a
preview of coming attractions in case
Biden Pelosi and Schumer are elected in
119 days